o psol ser ouvidos a mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma
mantenedora do papel que para mais ou
menos 15 elásticos vocês forem crianças
que quiserem fazer esse projeto peçam
ajuda o duto e na hora de carregar
utilizar a arma utilizada em óculos de
proteção
[Música]
então vamos começar a primeira coisa que
você tem que fazer é juntar duas folhas
tamanho a3 disse vocês não tiverem é só
juntar duas folhas tamanho a4 que são
aquelas normais de impressora para dar
uma cor aos tubos no final eu disse nem
uma folha de tamanho a4 com a cor verde
vocês conseguem ver como eu colei folha
no lado direito de não precisar de
enrolar uma folha de tamanho a3 já seja
fazer uma rifa foi caso vocês não
consigam fazer isso direito e vou deixar
um link de inscrição deste vídeo e este
livro vai servir para nós definimos o
diâmetro interno do nosso é bastante
simples depois vocês colocam rifa na
folha numa das extremidades e possebon
irlanda até a outra no final é só ver c
ficou bem feito tubo e foi escolar desta
forma
depois vocês têm que cortar e colar os
tubos da maneira que vocês estão vendo
aqui agora e opções forem fazer isso sem
colocar em causa ver tudo como instalar
e fazer igual e depois continuar a ver o
vídeo mais para frente para cortar o
tubo e utilizarem uma serra para metal
que ocupa agora um motor que tem uma
caixa de produção no pedaço foi muito
grande
depois coloquei neste buraco aqui e traz
agora depende muito do vosso motorock
vocês usarem muito maior então tem que
fazer um buraco maior tem que adaptar a
arma por um tutor que vocês utilizar em
seguida começam 14 dentro do lado que
não tem motor e faça um buraco mais ou
menos seis milímetros de diâmetro ou
seja o diâmetro de um lápis normal
depois curta e dois pedaços com 18
centros e clay nesta parte aqui da
frente vamos fazer outro susto mas este
aqui tem que ser maior mas não quis
polemizar três estão colocadas ao
contrário desta forma vocês vão
conseguir ter um tubo maior e vai se
destacar do resto da arma é que nós
vamos colocar os elásticos focando ficar
mais resistente vocês têm que rolar duas
rifas de uma ou outra podem usar cola ou
então fita cola fita crepe
aí num dos lados vejam que eu coloquei
bastante cola e este lado você tem que
ter cuidado com a imagem que eu vou
manter uma mola e vou deixar que isto
segue nesta posição e fica assim bem
acertado e quando vocês colocaram o caso
vejam que a parte afetada fica ao pé do
motor ou quem fica lá para
traz por fazer para pegar 10 do grupo 10
com oito centímetros ou mais vai
depender do tamanho da nossa mão e de
uma rifa tamanho a3 e depois vocês têm
que cobrar desta forma e encaixar aqui
nesta quarta ele ficar preso vocês
depois puxam para trás e tem por cola e
depois voltar empurrar para a frente por
fazer a cobertura da área vão precisar
de uma caixa dos cereais de
pequeno-almoço e desenhar o que vocês
viram anteriormente
depois de cortarem tem colar desta forma
e outro lado vocês vão precisar de por
alguns irmãos para assim poderem ver a
amargar e voltar a fechá-lo curricular
em outro lado eu tenho nenhuma intenção
para explicar simétrico cola em cinco
rodadas com cinco centros desta forma
pois faz um buraco na icon mesma broca
que vocês usaram anteriormente isso para
vocês têm que pular dos pedaços com três
centímetros e depois um cuidado com dois
centímetros no maio usar agora uma rifa
tamanho a 5 ou seja montado uma folha a4
e vai encaixar depois num tubo de 20
centímetros desta forma agora por um
pouco de cola para ele ficar preso
vou usar agora morre o tamanho a4 e vou
passar pelo tubo de três centímetros e
depois vou por um tubo de 20 centros em
cada extremidade e prender com cola e
agora vou juntar tudo para isso usar uma
rifa tamanho a4 mágico do brasil desta
forma e depois passei pela aquela peça
que tinha cinco tubos com cinco
centímetros e depois virei o chefe do
rio foi para dentro dos outros tubos que
estão por cima para conectar a outro
piloto jovem político mais ou menos seis
milímetros porém se vocês não tiverem
podem utilizar um lápis velho e agora
vocês conseguem ver como conectar o cano
ao registro da arma que na verdade não
fica preso vocês conseguem respirar para
depois poder e recarregar a arma
o circuito deste projeto aqui é bastante
simples basicamente temos um motor uma
bateria e depois um tutor que vocês
podem fazer o vosso próprio utilizando
dois clipes ou então podem usar um que
você já tiver em casa
vejam que vocês podem colocar a bateria
não volte a lhe daquela maneira nem
preciso colocar cola que fica bem
apertado e que vocês conseguem
ver como recarregar e nesta altura vocês
devem usar óculos de proteção
quando terminar vergar é só puxar a arma
e colocar o cano naquela parte da frente
e agora a partir daqui é de esperar e
ver se elas o filme só espero que vocês
tenham gostado e fiz este projeto porque
tem andado um pouco tempo e era uma
coisa que eu consegui fazer muito
rapidamente mas quando tiver mais tempo
faço outros projetos que já os tinha
falado isso obrigado até a próxima